I've always been somebody that likes to
follow interesting questions and that
initial work in Liz's lab was really a
curiosity driven question how can the
cell maintained his chromosome ends when
we know that they should be getting
shorter so it was a puzzle that we
needed to solve but it was an important
puzzle because all cells need to solve
this problem of replicating the
chromosome ends but I feel like I've
been really fortunate because at every
step then along the way I've been able
to follow my curiosity and see where the
next step left the next step led so for
instance I started off working on this
enzyme telomerase and trying to
understand how the enzyme actually
functions what are the different
components can we find out the mechanism
by which this enzyme operates and then
the question came up about cells and if
the telomeres are shortening every time
what would happen to cells and I got
then into this field of cellular
senescence which is the cells can divide
a certain number of times and then they
stop dividing and it turns out that the
short telomeres play a role in that so
that was a very interesting discovery
and that then led to the next question
which is if the cells normally stop
dividing why don't cancer cells stop
dividing that's a cell type that has to
divide many times so then our interest
went into the area of cancer research
and I was able to follow that because
it's very nice to be able to be in this
kind of environment where you can just
do science and as long as you're
learning something interesting and you
can get funded and I've been funded
continuously by the National Institutes
of Health and so that's been very nice
to then be able to follow the next steps
along the way in terms of what the most
interesting question was to me
at the time there were really two main
hypotheses for how telomers maybe
elongated that there could be a
recombination based model or this
hypothetical ends on and I just thought
it was like an exciting puzzle to to see
which might be true and so I chose one
because I was working with Liz which was
to look for an enzyme which might
lengthen telomeres and it was really
just fun to be part of solving that
puzzle
of course it could have been possible
that there
another mechanism that lengthen
telomeres and is not clear how long one
would then keep looking for something
without any success luckily in my case
it was about nine months of trying
various things and then had some success
but yes there are a number of dead ends
in science and you may be doing
experiments along one track and either
technically the experiments don't work
or you get something some slightly wrong
and that's what's really important about
the whole scientific process is that
it's really about what the what the
results are and either you or somebody
else will be able to determine whether
or not the results of your research are
correct and so being able to let go of
ideas and move forward I think is just
as important as having good new ideas